i told you recently that it was a really
bad launch for cnn plus cnn plus is the
streaming wing of cnn
under 10 000 viewers a day the david
pakman show is dramatically bigger than
cnn plus and they spent is it tens or is
it hundreds of millions of dollars on it
it's crazy and just like that cnn plus
is shutting down not even a month in
um warner brothers discovery is shutting
down cnn plus as of april 30 marking one
of the company's first significant
maneuvers since completing the merger of
warner media and discovery less than two
weeks ago
this puts an end to cnn plus
this decision is in line with wbd's
broader direct to consumer strategy said
chris licht the incoming ceo of cnn in a
complex streaming market consumers want
simplicity and an all-in service which
provides a better experience and more
value than stand-alone offerings i don't
think that's the case
i talked about this on a stream
we a little little old us and our
colleagues in independent progressive
media
we are not
part of a network we are not part of a
coordinated marketing strategy and yet
we have plenty of both audience that is
larger than cnn plus and audience
crossover the fact that if people want
to watch me
and then sam cedar
and then the young turks and that you
know whatever else right
we're
you can find us on youtube we have
youtube channels but you know our
podcasts are in different places we have
all different schedules when you call in
is completely different
and people watch all of the shows they
don't they don't need everything to be
an all-in all-in-one solution and i
think what the problem is that
cnn plus tried to capitalize generally
on the growth of streaming which may no
longer be growing i mean consider that
netflix saw a loss of subscribers for
the first time in history
that we may be reaching saturation at
this point in time but cnn plus wanted
to jump in generally on the popularity
of streaming
but they weren't bringing
known content in the sense of like
netflix and amazon prime at least you go
oh here's 10 shows i love i already love
them they're all there with cnn plus it
was original content
um on a platform that nobody had any
emotional connection to not that
everybody's emotional connection to me
is so positive right we have a lot of
haters but the idea here is well people
are in the audience because they want to
hear from me our team us our guests the
callers the community there was
absolutely no community aspect to cnn
plus the technology wasn't innovative or
notable
it's just it's just a dud there's no
other way to say it and we'll see if
some of these other services end up
going the same way it doesn't bring me
pleasure
but it makes me reassured
that it is not a clear you know
everybody likes to have a hot take about
what the future is early on the legacy
tv people were saying this streaming
thing is not going to take off well they
were wrong
then the streaming people said we're
going to have indefinite growth and
first mover advantage will prevent
netflix and amazon prime for ever having
any issues and growth started slowing
down and competitors entered the market
and you've got apple tv with ben
stiller's great show and all these
different things and so actually they
were wrong too
um there there's no one
path forward and i think the takeaways
are flexibility
genuine content and putting the
connection with the audience ideally
first rather than saying we're cnn we'll
just put a plus sign after it and people
want rand will want random shows our
friend rex chapman former nba player
he had i i hope that i'm right
he had or might continue to have i don't
know i saw some of what he was doing on
cnn plus it's cool i but i already know
rex and so that's the advantage and
everything about it was approached in a
way that that didn't really make sense
and it's over it's already being shut
down april 30th and think of the money
that was spent and again i've said this
before
if we got a cash infusion that was just
five percent of what was spent on cnn
plus
we
10x what we're doing i mean we take the
content that we've developed over time
which we know has led to a decade of
growth right we've never had a year
where we shrink we every year we grow
more than a decade 15 years
and we just dump that content in front
of tons of people by buying google ads
and youtube ads and twitter ads and all
this different stuff
we we don't try to reinvent the wheel we
just say let's put what we're already
doing that works in front of more people
and uh it would have been money much
better spent giving us five percent of
what it cost to launch cnn plus would
have been a much a much better
investment let me know your thoughts
about the new streaming wars
the at least temporary decline of
netflix the end of cnn plus all of it
find me on twitter at deepakman
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below